let's go to Micah from Idaho Micah from
Idaho not a heavily represented State
among live callers welcome Micah
hello thank you uh so I had two quick
questions if that's okay but first I
wanted to see how your New Years was did
you do anything fun or I had uh I had
dinner with some friends and uh my baby
daughter completely lost it and
um that was basically it yeah
oh dang
uh well but the good news was the
following was another kid
sneezed directly into my daughter's face
and my daughter didn't get sick so I
consider that a win
that is a win my dog sneeze on my face
basically every morning it's it's
fantastic your dogs highly recommend yes
can humans get like stuff from dogs they
can't right
um
like covid
um there are a couple of like parasites
that they can carry that dogs or that
humans can get to but for the most part
like parvo and like the things that they
typically deal with are more
specifically dogs all right well good
not good for the dogs good for the
humans I guess
sure but what's on your mind um
well I was gonna see so um
you had a caller mentioned the uh the
stunts with uh sending the migrants to
to different places where they're not
going like Kamala Harris's house yeah
Kamala Kamala
Kamala okay
I was just wondering so like I don't
really
see any political gain for anyone in
that situation like I have a hard time
seeing like what the right wing would
see as desirable
in that could you help me like
understand what's going on there like
wow so here's what they need to
understand to understand why Republicans
think that that's a good idea okay
Republicans have this ideology I guess
we would call it which we sometimes call
strict father morality which means that
people should suffer the consequences of
their actions if you have uh sexual
relations outside of marriage you should
have to suffer the consequences of
getting pregnant and carrying the child
to term you can't get a get out of jail
free card like birth control or the
morning after pill or an abortion right
even if those are solutions that there's
no real reason to to prevent being
available to people and similarly
Republicans believe and Micah you have
to get into the mind of the Republican
Republicans believe that it is Democrats
and not Republicans Democrats in blue
states that are saying open the Border
let everybody in no control at all right
even though Democrats aren't saying
these things this is the story
Republicans tell themselves so
Republicans believe if Democrats in blue
states are going to be the one letting
everybody in the immigrants should be
sent to the blue states to make those
blue States deal with the consequences
of letting everybody in it's all made up
Micah don't get me wrong but that's the
internal logic that they apply to it
that's why they think it's a great thing
to send the migrants to Martha's
Vineyard and DC from Texas and Florida
okay thank you that makes a little more
sense yeah I mean it makes no sense but
hopefully what they are thinking now you
understand which is insane
yes that is correct yeah all right all
right Micah thank you appreciate the
call
uh okay thanks all right there is Micah
from Idaho
with uh with a great question quite
frankly